Masalah saya dengan semua penghakiman untuk Lily Phillips adalah bahwa
di mana kemarahan yang sama
ketika itu terjadi pada wanita di balik pintu tertutup
dan mereka tidak mengambil keuntungan darinya?
Seperti Giselle di Prancis?
Ada kemarahan sekarang,
tapi tidak ada yang mengedipkan mata ketika itu terjadi.
Tak satu pun dari pria-pria itu angkat bicara.
Tidak ada yang mengutuk suaminya untuk itu.
Di mana kemarahan untuk wanita seperti Santonio Brown,
yang menghabiskan bertahun-tahun di penjara
ketika dia masih remaja diperdagangkan?
Seperti,
jangan bertingkah sangat marah.
Anda marah karena dia menikmatinya dan dia mendapat untung.
Karena tidak ada kemarahan sialan
ketika wanita biasa melakukan itu pada mereka,
dipaksakan pada mereka,
tidak ada kemarahan sialan.
Jadi sialan zip itu.
Zip it?
Seperti,
sialan tutup.